for me it wasn't that was never
the mental health has nothing to do with
just the trade you know it was a bunch
of things that i was dealing with as a
person in my personal life that i don't
really want to go into that to death
with
um
but yeah i'm here now so you know it's a
blessing to be you know in an
organization like this and you know i'm
just looking
forward to getting back on the floor and
building something great here for me it
just it made sense man it's a time where
i needed to be
uh you know
around guys that i know that want to win
and know that they do are willing to do
whatever it takes to win and
the structure here is is unbelievable
uh
that's the goal man that's the goal like
daryl said the opportunity to window is
now joel is playing the best he's ever
played
you know so my job is to come out there
and help him and help the entire team
win the championship this year and years
going forward
a few other notes from today before we
get to reaction hardin also said he will
opt into that player option when asked
if they really think he could win a
championship he said quote hell yeah and
the sixers were apparently his first
choice when houston was dealing ben
simmons also said he did not talk to
joel embiid and whether or not he would
play against the sixers in philadelphia
march 10th quote i hope so you said hmm
when james harden was talking what made
you go hmm well i mean when you say
you want to play with guys that want to
win yes what are you insinuating that
the guys in brooklyn
didn't want to win
is that what we're talking about i have
a question he started right away is that
tracy or is that bartholomew
no for real i mean that's what it sounds
like to me
right and we all know houston was his
first choice i mean uh philly was his
first choice before he went to brooklyn
so when things hit the fan
he wanted out of there he shut it down
he wasn't hurt no
he wasn't hurt he shut it down
you all think he's hurt right now no you
saw them step back
my point is that you're on rehab the boy
came out swinging baby
you don't really have a hammy by doing
step-by-step he has some things to get
off his chest yeah he got it off a
little bit yeah what was it like to
watch all that dwayne well
i mean i'm glad that it's over first of
all um it seems that
james has some things he has some things
he need to say and we all looking for
james to say those things but we're
looking for him to say it with joellenbe
to win a championship and that's the
reason he's there
um but i think about when i think about
ben what i'm happy about for ben is that
ben seems to be happy
and i know all the saying out there but
i got a chance to notice this young man
and i got a chance to be around him this
summer uh he he became a mentor to my
son i got a chance to see what he was
going through mentally and you just want
to see him in a better space and he
seems to be in a better head space
mentally and uh
i'm looking forward to seeing what he's
going to do over there are you ready to
say his name shaq no i'm always say his
name it's just
as a superstar as a professional nv
nba player
we don't always get our way
right and you know the problem where it
all started is
doc made the comment
he was upset
backlash boom boom boom and then the
mental health thing came in
the difference between mental health and
mental fortitude
you know
i
i'm not comparing them to me but
you don't think i've heard we can't win
with shaq
you don't think i heard shaq's not worth
120.
you don't think i heard don't even throw
it to trishak d way you shoot
heard it all and what makes us great is
we we learn how to persevere around all
of that
not going to get into the mental health
thing because i was in la yesterday i've
seen real mental health
you know many homeless people out there
and you just talk to them like they have
problems that we don't know about it
so i don't want to get into that i don't
want to have a you know conversation
with i wish him well
i wish him the best but that's when the
problem started like it just started as
a petty situation and then you throw the
mental health thing in
and i'm happy for
but the question is if this problem
arises again
what are you going to do because listen
i i heard it 20 years when i make my
3004 quarterback like oh it's ooh
let me miss them you don't think i get
emails and posts and death threats i i
don't heard it all seen at all i don't
got bull before so you know i just wish
that if this situation never comes
around again that it mentally he has a
tough enough mental fortitude to you
know be able to get through it because
again yeah we make a lot of money they
expect us to do things but we don't
always get our way and i've heard it all
ever since high school i've heard it all
but
i was raised by a guy who who don't want
to hear none of that right
suck it up it james harden has two
30-point triple-doubles in the last
three weeks we haven't seen ben on a
basketball court in eight months and i'm
i'm hearing people say they're on the
road for a champ what is
what is right to expect out of ben right
away for this nets team as a team that
doesn't have kd for the foreseeable
future well i think with him being out
all season i mean it's going to take
some time for him to get a great
basketball shake but i think what he
will provide is his defensive presence
he's really good at defense right and
i'm talking about to be able to guard
one through five he has that type of
versatility uh play-making ability he
has a high basketball iq i think he
could be a great playmaker those things
can translate right now immediately now
what everybody wants to see
hasn't been working on that jump shot is
he going to take jump shots this year
right that's what we want to see